BRENDAN KENNY: So
good morning.
My name is Brendan Kenny.
I'm an engineer with the Maps
Developer Relations team.
And I mostly work with
the JavaScript APIs.
So good old browsers.
And so, as you can see, I'm here
to tell you a story about
where maps and browsers and
geospatial data meet and make
beautiful, beautiful
things for us.
It says HTML5 up there because
I wanted to be cool, I guess,
but it's really about
modern browsers.
What are the new things that
browsers can bring to the
table and allow us
to do things that
we couldn't do before.
So how are you doing there?
There we go.
So the kind of catchphrase
of the day for
visualization is process.
And the reason why that is, and
a lot of the visualization
minds out there, the great
visualization minds out there,
are focusing on process, is that
visualization, it turns
out, is really difficult
to do well.
If we wanted to take it easy,
we could get a couple of
numbers together and pick a nice
font and maybe some clip
art, and you can have it like
a long vertical thing.
And it would be an
infographic.
And you'd get some
hits on Reddit.
And then a bunch of angry people
would come in and say
you're bad at statistics.
So we could do that.
But if you want to do a
visualization that that's
actually valuable and actually
gives insight and
communicates, it takes time.
And so what this kind of thing
that people have started
calling this time is process.
So Ben Fry, who is one of the
co-creators of Processing--
which is, if you haven't heard
of it it's, a kind of
computational sketchbook slash
programming environment.
It's great, I really like the
sketchbook part of that.
It's meant to kind of just
immediately start getting
something on the screen
and going so that
you can start exploring.
And in his book on data
visualization, he takes the
stages of process and divides
it into these kind of seven
categories.
And the exact categories
aren't that important.
There's definitely overlap.
And we could probably each have
our own definitions for
these words.
But it's actually a pretty good
way to think about it.
And what I don't have here, and
he actually has when he
first introduces this in the
book, is a bunch of arrows
that point back and forth
and back and forth.
And it turns out that's
what you have
to do for this process.
You don't go through stages
and then get to the end.
It turns out you get to midway
through and realize you had no
idea what you were doing, and
have to go back to the
beginning and take care
of your data.
So now that I have emphasized
the importance of these, I'm
going to lump the first three
together so I can dismiss them
as quickly as possible.
So these are actually
the hardest steps--
acquire, parse, and filter.
So this is really about your
data, your source data.
And it turns out this is
often definitely the
longest amount of time.
It tends to be the most
tedious part of a
visualization project because
data tends to be so horrible
in the real world, especially
as you get larger in the
amount of data.
I'm going to avoid saying that
phrase about voluminous
amounts of data.
But as the amount of data you
have increases, the likelihood
of error increases.
And just the raw number of even
somebody entering wrong
things on a keyboard, or much
more like subtle but
pernicious things like somebody
took a survey of data
using 1990s census tracts, and
somebody else took a survey of
data using 2000 census tracts.
And then you want to compare
them, but it turns out in your
area, the census tracts
don't actually align.
And then you're going to have
make some pretty serious
assumptions about how things
average over areas that only
intersect but aren't the same.
So there's a bunch of tools
out there to help you with
these steps.
You import the data.
You look what's wrong.
All the way down from just
libraries, a lot of Python
libraries exist.
If you are a fan of R,
this is great for it.
One thing that I'll put a plug
in for is Open Refine, which
used to be called
Google Refine.
It's a great program
that you can run.
And it's specifically for
this type of thing.
You put in your data, and you
run what are called filters.
So for this unemployment column,
you say, show me
everything that's not a
number because this is
supposed to be a number.
And it might turn out somebody
entered strings in there for
some reason.
And then you can write a really
quick little snippet in
the little Refine programming
scripting
language to correct those.
And it turns out this is kind of
what happens, big or small,
what you have to do.
You have to look at your data
and say, what doesn't belong?
And there's a lot of tricks that
you can do to get there.
So this is hard.
And the kind of data that I want
to use, for WebGL stuff,
which we're going to get to in
just a second, it tends to be
high in count, and so there
tends to be errors in it.
And as I said, I'm going to
kind of pass over this now
because there's an awesome
session just after lunch in
Room 1, which is somewhere down
the hall, called All the
Ships in the World.
And it's about gathering
data from all the
ships in the world.
So you can imagine, it's
quite a bit of data.
And it's a great session,
specifically, about how you
get kind of nasty, poorly
formatted, sometimes just
erratic data, clean it up, put
it through a pipeline so that
you can process that large a
volume of data, and then start
serving it fast enough that
you can start doing
interactive queries on it, and
so you can actually take a
look at things, and a little
graph, and say, oh, that
little lump in that distribution
does not belong
there, so let's go figure
out what that is.
So I definitely recommend it.
12:45 after lunch.
So what we're going to do is
treat that course as a little
awesome black box and
use their data.
So we're going to take a look at
All the Ships in the World
and just try our hand at
visualizing it and kind of
exploring the data.
So this is about the process of
figuring out what are the
interesting stories here.
So the data comes from
SpaceQuest, a company called
SpaceQuest.
And it turns out that ships
broadcast a bunch of data
about themselves.
They have transmissions that
they sent out periodically
talking about who they
are, where they are,
what they're doing.
And it's primarily for collision
avoidance and in
harbors and things like that,
for traffic control.
But all the ships broadcast
it out.
And so SpaceQuest has a
satellite overhead.
And they pick it up.
And they log it.
And so we've partnered
with them to kind of
explore what's possible.
If we were to visualize this
kind of data, what kind of
things could we do?
So let's talk about Represent,
representations.
Finding a representation.
So this is something that's part
of my personal process,
finding something on screen as
quickly as possible so that I
can get a look at the data
and see what's going on.
So a year ago at I/O, I released
a library called
CanvasLayer.
It's in the Google Maps
Utility Library.
If you just look for
CanvasLayer, one word, it's
usually in the top hits.
So it's a Maps API.
How many people here are
familiar with the Maps API,
the JavaScript Maps API?
OK, would you rate yourself as
you have made more than two
maps that you didn't directly
copy paste from the samples?
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, OK, I mean,
no it's totally fine.
I just am curious about
what level of
detail I should go into.
So the Maps API has a concept
called overlays.
And they're exactly what
they sound like.
Chrome doesn't like when I go
full screen to other tabs.
So this is a ground overlay.
And it's literally an image
put on top of the ground.
And so the key thing
with overlays--
the kind of overlays in the Maps
API parlance-- is that
you take an object.
And it's associated with
a point in the world.
And so when you move, and
when you zoom, it
stays put at that point.
So that's great.
And you can do nice things like
overlay historical data
on top of here.
So CanvasLayer is a
layer because it
doesn't quite do that.
But it tries to emulate that.
Did that actually work?
Oh, cool.
There we go.
So CanvasLayer takes an HTML5
canvas and puts it right on
top of a map and let's you draw
anything you want to canvas.
And if you're not familiar,
canvas is supposed to be a
dynamic image element.
And so it originally had a 2D
API that's based off drawing
APIs of old.
But then more recently, a 3D API
was added, WebGL, which is
based on OpenGL, yes, 2, but
it's basically OpenGL
bindings, emulated or not,
through the browser.
So you can use the canvas
as your place to draw.
I'm sure most people have seen
a WebGL thing by now.
I guess we saw a bunch
yesterday.
So here's our canvas.
And the main thing is--
ooh, that's no good.
The main thing to see
here, though, is--
it's a little hard
to understand--
is that the canvas actually
stays still.
So the canvas covers the whole
map, and it doesn't
move with the map.
And the difference is, what
you're doing is instead
logically moving the content.
And so there's a callback
every frame, so on a
RequestAnimationFrame, to
redraw the content.
And for 2D canvas, it's
not that important.
You could kind of
do some tricks.
But for WebGL, it turns out it's
really important because
every wasted pixel in WebGL is
possibly a significant cost
with wasted pixels.
So you don't want anything
sliding offscreen
that you can't see.
And you don't want to allocate a
bigger canvas than you need.
So that's what we do.
And so it's just something,
too, that you have to deal
with when you're dealing
with CanvasLayer.
But it's not terribly difficult
to understand.
So CanvasLayer is created like
a lot of Maps API objects.
You create a canvas layer
with a constructor.
You pass it a configuration
object.
The most important things are
the map that you want to
actually put it on and the
update function, so that
function that's called
back every frame.
There's other options.
It's all in the docs if you
want to take a look.
And so here's an example of
the 2D transformation that
we're doing.
And there's a direct analog
to it in WebGL.
So we're calculating a scale.
So as you zoom in, you can think
of the world as scaling
rather than zooming.
And it's to the power
of the zoom.
And then you have an offset,
which is just the translation
as you pan around.
And then the context.scale and
context.translate are part of
the 2D drawing API that
actually let you
transform the canvas.
So then I can just say draw
a square, and it will
correctly place it.
So that's the 2D canvas.
And we don't care about
it anymore.
So we have a canvas that
we can draw to.
We have data from an awesome
black box that's covered
really well at 12:45, All
the Ships in the World.
You should go.
And we need to get the data from
there into the canvas.
So there's a couple
of different ways.
Oh, that's exciting.
OK, whatever.
So we have CSV, which ends up
poorly wrapping, often.
And that's the tried
and trusted way.
Whatever, if you really like
spreadsheets, if you know
people that really like
spreadsheets, you probably
could get CSV pretty quickly.
A million libraries can import
it and parse it for you.
If you go talk to the
Perfmatters guys upstairs in
the Chrome booth area, they'll
tell you not to mess
with this too much.
As it gets bigger, you start
generating a lot of strings.
And modern JavaScript engines
are really good at doing
offsets into strings because
strings are read only.
But you can quite easily
generate a ton of garbage.
And then everything
slows down.
So that's no good.
So we'll look for something
better.
JSON is the classic thing.
Hopefully, everybody is
familiar with JSON.
It has a nice direct translation
to the object
literal from JavaScript, which
is what JSONP is based on.
And all the browsers, for years
now, have had support
for json.parse, which is a
native method to safely parse
Jason into JavaScript objects.
It's really fast.
There's a couple of downsides.
People tend to make deep
objects with JSON, even
without meaning to.
GeoJSON is a really beautifully
simple format, and
yet people still end up taking
features and putting them in
feature sets, and then they have
geometries, but they're
also siblings to other
features which
have feature sets.
And you end up having to write
general tree callers just to
find all the things.
The other thing is just size.
So the numeric type in
JavaScript is a 64-bit float.
And that's eight bytes
on the wire.
And you can see that right
here we have some
lat longs or something.
And every character over eight
characters is an extra byte.
And you actually want
that because
you want the precision.
A 64-bit floating point has 14
decimal places of precision.
And so you want that, but
you start wasting space.
Gzip does help.
Don't let me make it
sound too bad.
But you do end up paying
the price.
So all of which is to say, the
most beautiful thing, the most
wonderful thing, is
typed arrays.
So typed arrays came
along with WebGL.
Is everybody familiar
with typed arrays?
Yes?
No?
OK.
So typed arrays are kind
of what you would
think in C as an array.
It's a contiguous
block of bytes.
And you say to the browser, give
me these number of bytes.
And then you can just fill it
in with whatever you want.
And so what's great about that
is, when you get a message
from a server with XHR2, which
has been around for a little
while now, you can actually
set the response
type on your XHR.
And so that basically tells the
browser, don't mess with
anything here.
Don't parse.
Don't send it through some
string engine, and back to
binary, or something awful.
Just give me the
bytes directly.
And so you can see here that,
what I'm doing is, I take this
response, which is the array
buffer, and then I'm putting
it in a float 32 array.
And so I think a lot of people,
when they encounter
typed arrays, they think of
float 32 array, and int 32
array, and float 64 array
because you think of it, it's
a typed array.
You have a data type throughout
an array.
But actually, those are what are
called type array views.
And it's great because you can
actually have multiple views
on the same buffer.
So say you had, for instance,
alternating float and ints.
So in the data that we're about
to see, our time stamps
couldn't fit in a float 32
without losing precision.
And so we can fit them
in an int 32.
And so I can actually
get two views.
I could do a new int 32 array
on this.response, and just
alternate as I iterate through
the array, and take a look at
them because they just interpret
the underlying bytes
the way that you tell them to.
So they're my favorite thing.
They let us have JavaScript
the way that we want it.
There's the loose, scripty, just
throw it out on the page
that everybody does.
And there's the snooty, I do
everything with promises and
wrapped up callbacks.
And if it's not a monad, then I
don't want to hear about it.
And then there's the asm.js
hacker types that just want to
do some bit twiddling
sometimes.
And we can merge all of them.
And it's beautiful.
So I apologize for this long
to actually draw something.
So let's take a look at some
really simple points.
So this is taking data from all
the ships in the world.
And actually, the query is,
what are all the latest
positions of ships
that you've seen.
So the satellite, actually,
is in a polar orbit.
And so it only sees ships
every once in a while,
whenever they're underneath.
And so, typically, I don't
remember my orbital mechanics
exactly, but it depends on the
Earth turning, actually,
underneath the polar orbit
to see everything.
And so it only sees what's in
its line of sight, and so
there's a certain amount
of time since
you've last seen a ship.
And if ships turn off their
receivers, we might not see
them for months.
So here's an image
of all of them.
And as of this morning,
I think it was
about 79,000 points.
So if you are familiar with web
mapping, this is actually
a huge amount of points.
It's not unheard of.
It's not it's not completely
out of a normal range.
But typically, with regular
markers, you
might have a few hundred.
You can use optimized markers or
some kind of canvas tricks
for more than that.
But what we have here is very
quickly interactive.
And remember that this is
actually redrawing every frame
that that's actually
being done.
And so it's actually quite
nice and fast.
So this is just a very
simple drawing.
I'm just taking the lat
long And I'm filling
a box around it.
So that's great.
And we can see, already, that we
have plenty of performance
room that we can start kind
of abusing our GPU.
Because what are those fans for
but running at full speed?
Makes sense to me.
So just to give you a look at
what we're doing to get those
blocks on screen, if you've
never seen WebGL code before,
this might be a little
shocking.
It's a very C-like API, on
purpose, to make it very easy
to port old OpenGL code.
It's really not that bad, and
there's a ton of libraries out
there to wrap it.
I personally would
suggest three.js.
I don't use it that much, but
there's a huge community to
support that.
And the three.js people are so
fast in Stack Overflow, I
never get to answer anything.
So they're ready to help you.
And it wraps it in a bunch
of kind of very familiar
JavaScript objects and
helper classes.
So it can help you out.
But here's just looking
at raw WebGL.
So we get a WebGL context by
asking-- so CanvasLayer has a
canvas on it.
And we ask for the
WebGL context.
I put this in specifically on
its own slide because I'm
really excited.
It used to be experimental WebGL
until a few months ago.
WebGL was finally ratified.
And it's now no longer
experimental.
We have enough conforming
browsers to do it.
So that's Firefox, and we have
Chrome, and Opera on Windows,
I think, and then Firefox on
mobile, Chrome on mobile, if
you go to about flags and turn
it, on and then Safari as well
if you go to the developer
menu and turn on WebGL.
So we have a lot of platforms
available.
That's a huge amount of market
share, depending on
how you count it.
And then I'll let you search on
the web for, I don't know,
IE11 and WebGL.
And you might find some
interesting rumors.
But I won't comment.
I am encouraged, though.
So this is kind of pretty
typical WebGL code.
Again, don't worry too much
about the specifics.
But what this is doing here is,
we're creating a buffer.
WebGL is very state based.
And so you create buffers, and
then you say, WebGL, here's my
current buffer, like
bind this.
And now I want to give this data
to the current buffer,
rather than saying, current
buffer, here's some data.
It's feels a little bit--
I don't know.
So that's what we're
doing here.
We're binding a buffer, and
we're passing raw data here.
And if you remember, raw data
was that array buffer that we
got off the wire from our XHR.
And now we can just pass
it directly into WebGL.
It's a beautiful thing.
If you don't have to do any
processing, if you've already
processed on the server, you can
just pass it on in and no
work needs to be done.
So that's the fastest thing to
compute is no computation.
And then you do this thing
where you bind it to a
variable to these shaders that
I'm about to show you.
And you tell it these kind of
esoteric long string of
parameters here.
But I'm telling it it's a vector
of two components.
So its a latitude
and longitude.
And the type is float.
And I tell it where to
find it in the array.
And it's just lat long, lat
long, lat long, right in one
long array.
So then we create what
are called shaders.
And they are kind
of a misnomer.
They used to be just for
shading, but now we can pretty
much use them for whatever
we want.
There's a great blog series
by Gregg Tavares, who's an
engineer on Chrome.
And it's called WebGL
as a 2D API.
And it's a really great look at
how, with the way that GPUs
have kind of generalized, that
the 3D is kind of incidental.
It's very optimized for 3D, but
we think of these 3D APIs
as a means to games and
things like that.
But there's no reason
for that.
We can draw fancy 2D things,
for instance.
So we create these shaders.
And they're special programs
in a special scripting
language that is a different
language than JavaScript, but
it is very C-like.
And its very small.
So there's not much to learn.
And it's highly typed.
So it's easy to make a mistake,
but you know pretty
much instantly because
the compiler
complains quite quickly.
So you create your shaders.
And you bind them.
And so what happens on the
inside is, you've told it that
your array is broken up into
x, y, x, y, x, y, x, y.
And so the GPU actually has a
ton of, essentially, parallel
processors all on its chip.
And it can run these extremely
quickly and a
lot of them at once.
This machine, for instance, is
just a laptop, and it has a
few hundred that it
can run these
calculations at the same time.
So it runs a bunch of
things through.
And so you run it through
this vertex shader.
And here's a very simple
vertex shader.
I'm taking that world
coordinate, that lat long.
I'm taking a matrix
that encodes
that scale and translate.
And then I'm just
multiplying it.
And GLSL, the language, has a
bunch of handy things like 4
vectors, and 4 by 4 matrices,
and things like that.
So don't worry too much if
you're not big on this.
Like I said, there's lots of
libraries to help you out.
But the point is, the vertex
shader, the output here in
this vertex shader is
gl_position, a global
that you write to.
And all you have to do is write
somewhere on the screen,
between negative 1 and 1 and x,
and negative 1 and 1 and y,
and as long as you do that, it's
going to be on screen.
If it's offscreen, then it's
going to get clipped somehow.
And so that's all the vertex
shader is responsible for is
outputting an x, y coordinate.
And then you can include extra
coordinates if you're going to
be in 3D and can absorb it later
on down the pipeline.
So depending on what you told
WebGL you're drawing, in this
case, we might have said, I'm
drawing triangles, and so
it'll actually take the three
x, y pairs in a row and bind
them together in a triangle.
And so then it says, OK, these
three are in a triangle.
You told me three positions
on the screen.
So every pixel inside that
logical triangle I'm
going to fill in.
And there's rules for those
partial pixels, which ones are
filled and which ones aren't.
And then, finally, the last part
of the pipeline is, for
each of those pixels, you get
to run another program.
So you can run even more
computations per pixel, which
gets kind of crazy.
And that's what kind of
separates this from canvas 2D,
especially.
Even as a canvas speeds up,
and even as SVG speeds up,
there's really nothing that
can compare to running a
rather complex program
per pixel.
And again, the fragment shader
only has one job,
is to output a color.
So I created a little thing that
lets you edit shaders.
And so this is the shader that's
actually running on
that map that we just saw,
just to remind you.
Here it is.
So we're drawing squares,
black squares.
So in this case, we
have one point.
And so in my vertex shader, I'm
just directly outputting
the x, y, which is 0, 0.
And I'm using points this
time, which come
out as little sprites.
And I'm saying that the point
size, which is the other
variable you can output for
points, it's 256 pixels across
and 256 pixels downwards.
And then, finally, the
fragment shader,
I'm not doing anything.
I'm saying for every pixel
that's in this point, I'm
outputting an RGBA of
black, so 0001.
And so, finally, when I run
that, I have my black pixel.
So that's very exciting, but
we can do better than that.
So it turns out, as I said, you
can run whole programs in
these things.
And people actually run
incredibly complex programs.
If you've ever looked at Shader
Toy, it's actually
designed specifically just to
draw two triangles to fill up
the whole screen.
And then everything else
is run per pixel.
And you can run very elaborate,
even ray tracing,
just through that one pixel.
So we can be simpler
than that.
But we can use this built in
variable called gl Point
Coordinate, which is
within this square.
And the point coordinates of the
square has yet a different
coordinate system,
which is great.
But it basically runs from
0, 0 to 1, 1 like that.
And so the center of
it is 0.5, 0.5.
So I can say that the distance
for a particular pixel-- so
remember, this is running
per pixel--
is equal to the length of gl
Point Coordinate, the x, y
components of that, and then
subtracted from a vector of
0.5, 0.5, which is the center.
And so that's my distance from
the center of that circle.
And so I just want to test it.
Let's see.
Alpha is equal to--
if distance is greater than 0.5
away, so past that circle,
then let's make that
an alpha of 0.
Otherwise, let's
make it opaque.
And now we can just multiply
our color by alpha.
And that's not right.
Luckily, we have a debugger.
No matching overhead found.
Which line?
Vec2.
There we go.
So now I've clipped everything
past 0.5 distance away from
the center, and I've made
it transparent.
And so now, if we look over
in our points, we
can do the same thing.
And we can make nice
blue circles.
So Already we have a slightly
better looking map.
And that's just the start.
So the next thing we might want
to do is, so now have a
representation.
We have our other points
on the map.
And actually, we should
take a look at this.
I've looked at this too much,
and so I get jaded.
So this is about 79,000 ships
over the last month or two.
And they're older than last week
if they've docked, and
they stopped there, and actually
turned off their
transceiver, or something's
messed up, or sometimes ships
even change call
signs and IDs.
And so you think the
ship is gone, but
really it's a new ship.
But you can see lots of
interesting things.
So already, we can tell where
the major shipping lanes are,
where a lot of ships are.
These are actually, they have
a slight alpha on them.
And so you can see, when they
really bunch up here, that
there are quite a few.
And then there's amusing things
like where people are
very strict about shipping
lanes, like down here, or
where they're less strict about
shipping lanes, where
they just kind of go for it.
And then you can see, obviously,
one of the busiest
shipping straits in the world
is right through here.
And so a huge number of shipping
companies pass
through there.
And we can come over here, and
there's interesting things.
You can see the Panama Canal.
You can see ships approach
and come in, and
then fan back out.
It's quite cool.
So this is our representation.
We can go with this for now.
And so we want to start
mining, is the
next Ben Fry stage.
And so we need data.
We need to be able to
pick into this.
And so, when I say picking,
I mean it.
So picking points-- picking is
the kind of classic graphics
term for literally saying, like,
I pick that-- like where
your mouse is.
And so it is basically sampling
what is at that place
that you clicked and giving
you something back.
Now one of the advantages that
SVG fans tout about SVG is
that they're actually
elements in the DOM.
And so you can add a click event
to it, and then it works
just like any other click
event in a browser.
And it is great.
But it runs into trouble when
you can't really add 80,000
points to an SVG element and
expect it to perform well--
yet.
They keep improving.
So we have to do it manually,
which is no fun.
And so I've written some
code that does this.
And actually, three.js has
a picking library.
I've never used it in 2D.
But I think it should work.
And so the key is right here,
the gl.readPixels right here
in the middle.
And what you do is, you
transform the world so that
where you just clicked
is now at 0, 0.
And you just say, read me back
from that OpenGL frame buffer,
what color is at that pixel?
And you only want one pixel
because it's actually quite
expensive to bring stuff back
from the GPU, just as it's
expensive to push things--
expensive relative to
a steady frame rate.
So you might pay even five
milliseconds for this call,
and the latency increases as the
amount of memory increases
that you want to bring over.
So I included this code just
because I love typed arrays so
much right at the top.
So what I do is, I first create
a ReadBytes, and it's a
Uint8 array.
So it's an array
of four bytes.
And then I take a
pixelReadInt.
So the type is Int.
And it's an Int32 array of the
buffer of that Uint8 array.
So it's taking that four byte
array and shoving it into a
single int.
And what's cool about this is,
when you sample a color from
the screen, it's an RGBA.
And it's fitting into
four bytes.
And so I can read those
separately.
It'll be like 255, 128, 36,
and then 1 or whatever for
alpha, or 255 for alpha.
But then I can look down here
the bottom, this last line,
and I can do a look up table
on the int value of that.
So I can make a table
of values.
And as long as my values fit
into an int, I can then just
shove them into a color.
And OpenGL will just treat
it as a color.
And so that's exactly
what I've done.
So I have an ID for each ship.
And I shove it into a color.
And I never actually draw
it onscreen, but
we can look at it.
And it's really pretty.
It's kind of unpleasant
to look at.
But it doesn't matter because
we never see it.
And it's because each of these
is a unique color.
We have a huge range here.
Alpha gets a little tricky,
but we have at
least 24 bits of values.
And so what happens is, I click
on here, and I get the
single pixel that's
under my mouse.
And I read back what that ID.
And then I can look up in
a table to find it.
And so let's find out.
We actually have different
amounts of data for different
types of ship.
So here's the New Venture.
It's a cargo ship.
We last saw it on May 5.
And it's speeding ahead at 11.8
knots on a course of 27.4
degrees, so mostly north.
And meanwhile, let's find
a different one with a--
there we go.
The Falcon traveler, it's
another cargo ship.
But it's traveling south.
So we can now do that.
And so now, when we see kind of
curious ships, like say in
the middle of nowhere in land,
we can be like, well what's
going on here.
And so we don't have
a ship name.
But we can then use the MMSI,
which is there, which is kind
of an ID for it that you have
to register somewhere.
And we can look it up.
We can look up the country and
then the registration office.
And so usually what happens
is, it's a mistake.
So either the GPS on the ship
messed up, or there's even
cases were lightning has struck
the GPS antenna and
fried the electronics, and
suddenly a ship will be
teleporting all over Earth.
And unfortunately, it's very
difficult to tell if it's a
mistake or not because a lot of
this is standardized in a
way that allows you to--
you come on shift, and you're
just a guy, and you're kind of
on the deck.
And you're typing in your ship
ID, and hopefully you got it
right because you're
broadcasting to the
world who you are.
So a lot of it is
not automated.
So it can be very messy.
And All the Ships in the World
covers some of that, how you
kind of figure out, if two ships
have the same ID, and
one's in South America, and
one's in England, maybe
they're not the same ship.
But then you really hope that
they never come together
because then you can't
tell them apart.
OK, so now we have picking.
So we can kind of dig
a little bit deeper.
I really like that you can see
ships on the Mississippi.
I think that's awesome.
So now we can dig a
little bit deeper.
So we actually get more
complicated data down from the
server than just x,
y coordinates.
We actually can get a whole
bunch of attributes that come
with the ship.
So ships actually broadcast
quite a bit more.
They broadcast, as you've seen
from the info windows, they
broadcast the direction they're
travelling, their
current speed, and then
some other attributes.
And so what we can do is
actually take those and shove
those into WebGL as well.
And even though they're not
spatial coordinates, we can
use those to do the same thing
we're doing here, color them
by that value.
So let's see, is this
what I want to do?
Yes.
So this is one that seems like
it's just as ugly as the
picking one.
But actually, you'll start to
see some coherence in the
colors, especially around places
like here, where you
can see that there's obviously
a line of ships
with the same color.
And then we come down, and
you'll see, even here, where
you have much more distinct,
it's kind of party colors,
very distinct shipping lanes.
And so what we're doing is,
I'm not a designer.
If I was, this would
look prettier.
But what I'm doing is just
taking the course that the
ship is traveling in, and just
taking the color wheel of hues
and assigning a direction
to a hue.
So north is red, and then
it goes from there.
And so what we can see
here is coherence
in direction traveling.
And so remember, we're just
exploring data here.
You wouldn't want to send
this to your end user.
But you can start to see, first
of all, you can sanity
check is my data correct?
Like, yes, so if I look in the
Suez Canal, typically, ships
are moving in the
same direction.
You might lose your heading if
you're still, for instance.
So we can't be totally sure that
those aren't errors, but
we see enough coherence that
this is actually a valuable
insight into the data.
And then we can also start
seeing things like this where,
as a person who doesn't know
that much about shipping, I
immediately suspect that this
is a major shipping channel.
And that it must be either
advantageous enough to cut
across like this because it's
a short distance, and it's
near the equator, so it could
be a great circle, or it's
some kind of mandated thing
by governments, or
something like that.
And you can even see, as you get
close, that the ships on
top are very distinctively going
269, which is west for
you, that way.
And then the guys in the bottom
are going the opposite
way, almost directly.
So almost directly east/west.
So that's great.
And in fact, you can assign
any color to those
things that you want.
So then the last thing is that
you want to start getting
insight into more than that.
So we can look at this, and it's
difficult because there's
a lot of data on screen.
It's difficult to get a feel
for what's going on,
especially in confettiville
over here in the Gulf.
And this isn't unexpected.
There's actually a bunch of oil
platforms out here, and
ships that to go to and
from, and then a bunch
of tankers as well.
And oil platforms, I didn't know
this until recently, oil
platforms actually
count as ships.
And so they actually broadcast
their IDs because I guess
they're tethered, and actually,
they might be
drilling, unless they're
refineries.
But they're floating.
And this is also--
like, party town.
So what we can do is actually
get another
view into the data.
And so I actually really
like this.
And it's difficult to explain
why because it's not that
interesting.
But if you think of the classic
model view controller,
we've actually kind of split
both the model and the view--
well, depending on how you
define them, but whatever--
into a GPU side and
a CPU side.
So we have a GPU side that's
taken, we've loaded all of our
data over there.
And the only things that we
sent over are things like,
well, here are the lat longs,
so only draw the things in
that lat long.
And only scale it by this
amount, and don't draw
anything off the screen.
Meanwhile, on the CPU side,
I do things like read
back from the GPU.
But all I'm reading back
is that one index.
And so we can take that further
and actually do
computations on the CPU.
And that's great because the
CPU is not doing anything
while the GPU is crunching
away at these numbers.
And if we really want to get
those fans at full speed, what
we can do is actually
plot things.
You see that?
I wonder if I can--
yeah, well, the country's
all messed up now.
There we go.
So we lost some crispness.
But that's OK.
It's better to see this big.
So what this is, it's
a histogram of the
speeds of the ships.
And it changes as
we go around.
It actually changes the
current view of the
speeds of the ship.
So first of all, the thing
that always wins
is zero over here.
So there's always enough ships
at rest that that's going to
be the biggest bucket.
And in fact, the bucket goes
like up to India here, but I
clipped it off because it makes
everything else very
small if I normalize by that.
And so remember, this
is a distribution.
So this not a bar graph
of the total.
This is just taking a look at,
if you count the current ships
on screen as 100%, this is
a division of that full
distribution.
So you can normalize in your
head by root 2 pi whatever.
So what's interesting about this
is, you can start to see,
well A, everybody seems to
travel at about 12 knots,
which is a little slower than
I would've thought.
But you can see definite
patterns.
So where's a good pattern?
So off this Eastern Seaboard,
people are kind of doing a lot
of shipping.
And so you have these
ships coming in
from across the ocean.
And so they're tending to go
pretty fast because you spend
more time at sea, the more
expensive it is.
But as I was mentioning,
in the Gulf
it's quite a bit different.
You actually have
very slow ships.
So first all, your
oil platforms
aren't necessarily moving.
They might fall in
the 0 category.
But the ships that service
them are also quite slow.
And so you actually have, as you
come around here, you have
this really nice bimodal
distribution which you never
get to see enough of where you
have definite slow ships, and
you have fast ships.
And so this can help you start
to investigate your data.
And then you can start looking
at things, like, so what I've
done here is actually,
it's hard to tell.
But I've actually colored it.
I'm bending by everything that's
this light blue, which
is an unfortunate choice, but
that's OK, is not moving.
And everything that's dark blue
is moving at some speed.
And you can even color
it the same way
that we do with course.
So that's looking this thing.
And this is, I should say, this
is using the Crossfilter
library, that comes from--
Mike Bostock wrote it.
And then it's drawing with D3,
which Mike Bostock also wrote,
is the little histogram.
It's basically the simplest
little histogram
that you can write.
But you can drop this in for any
variable in the data set.
And actually, so this afternoon,
when All the Ships
in the World shows, we actually
have a few more that
we can show that time, but
I need to press on.
So the last thing I wanted to
show before we go to questions
is that here, I showed that
you can clip the alpha and
have a distinct circle.
And so this is actually drawing
a square still, but
it's just drawing invisible
pixels around a circle.
But there's no reason that
we have to do that.
So what we could do instead is
actually draw with functions.
So for instance, instead of
doing distance as this link
and then cutting off the alpha,
we could, instead, do
something like take the distance
and set it equal to 1
minus dist times 2.
And so if you remember the
distance to the edge is 0.5
because that's the edge
of the circle.
So we multiply it by
2 to get to one.
And then we invert it so that
zero's at the center.
No, one is at the
center, yeah.
And so now, if we
take this dist--
actually no, we want to do
one thing, just in case.
dist equals max 0.
So we clamp it at zero so we
don't draw out of range.
We can now do something
like this.
And what you see is, you
quickly get a function.
Or it's a fall off function
that's put on top of that dot.
So you can do anything here.
And you can do quite
complicated things.
And so what you can start
thinking about is taking
functions and geometry, and
what's called convolving them,
and so you can actually have a
function that's spread out
over geometry.
And that's the last thing
I wanted to show you.
If we think about, instead of
points, we say, OK, so this is
the latest positions
of these ships.
What about if we look at the
paths that these ships have
actually traveled?
So that was about
79,000 ships.
And instead, we're going to
look at about 20,000.
So less ships, but we're
actually going to look at a
bunch of data points per ship.
And so we're going to end
up with about two
million paths on screen.
So you should see,
there we go.
It's a little difficult to
see with these lights.
That's unfortunate.
So what you can see now is, as
we zoom in, you can actually
see these ships moving.
And you can see some of the
errors in the data where they
cut across Saudi Arabia.
Probably, that's just the
sampling of the data.
If the ship has made it around
the cape there in a day, then
they'll be drawn straight
through it.
But you can quickly see, as it
builds up, that you can see
those same shipping
lanes building up.
And we can do things like fall
off to blue and more
transparent over time.
And so the newer ships, the
ships that are actually
passing by, are these
bright orange.
And the older ships are
the darker pink.
And then we can do things.
It's difficult to see, but it's
easier-- you can come put
to the sandbox afterwards and
come see for yourself at full.
It's a Retina screen, too.
But what we're actually doing
is taking an error function.
And we're putting that
over the line.
So it's not just a line.
It's also an error function.
And it's an attempt I'm kind
of playing around with--
can we take GPS error and
kind of visualize it.
So we have an uncertainty
of where the ship is.
We know it was here, and we
know it was here with some
amount of error.
And we know it got between
them somehow.
And so we want to start
thinking about, can we
quantify the error?
And can we draw it by actually
spreading out and kind of
having a sum of all possible
ships that go through.
And so it's a pretty fun area.
And I think we're just
starting with
that particular thing.
But polylines are something that
have been ignored for too
long as kind of an interesting
geometric thing, especially in
Maps because while we can draw
polylines, it turns out
polylines are expensive, and in
many ways, more expensive
than polygons to draw.
And I did want to show just
a couple of things.
I can leave while I
go for questions.
But you can see already some
interesting things that we
couldn't pick up in just
the point data
like, here around Iceland--
there they are.
You'll see there's definite
ships that are tracking and
doing cargo.
But then as we get close to
the end here, you'll see
fishing vessels go out and
kind of swirl around
and come back in.
And you can only see that
pretty much through the
behavior of the lines, which
is pretty cool to see.
So I'll open it up
for questions.
We have about eight minutes.
I apologize for going over.
There's a lot more to show.
So I'll just kind of--
I like this area
in Alaska, too.
But so I just wanted
to say thank you.
And as I said, there's a bunch
of resources online, a bunch
of libraries for WebGL.
CanvasLayer, if you look for
it, it has two sample apps,
they are very simple, a 2D app
and a WebGL app just to get
you started.
And the 2D app does, I think,
exactly what you saw.
It draws a square.
And the WebGL app just generates
a bunch of random
points and plops them
down on a map.
So you can kind of use
it and copy it.
And I think there was even a
blog post where somebody
deciphered my code and
made it nicer.
So you might look
for that, too.
So if anybody has questions,
please come up to
the mic and ask away.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
coloring on a pixel by pixel
basis, how do you do things
like sprites?
Do you have a buffer that
represents the sprites, then
you look at the pixel offset in
there and draw that color
at that exact point?
Or how do you do more complex
things than dots?
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, more complex
So you were asking about
sprites, like image sprites?
Yeah, so obviously this
3D stuff is used for
games all the time.
And so games are often
based on, actually,
texturing and things.
And so, yeah, you just
load up a bunch of
images onto your GPU.
And then you can just get
those pixel offsets.
The same thing I was using for
the function to do a distance,
you can use that to look
up into your sprite.
And you say, like, this
is a gray pixel.
This is a red pixel.
This is a gray pixel.
And it seems like it would
be slow, but it's not.
And you get your little 2D
sprite art before you know it.
So that's typically
what you do.
AUDIENCE: And also, is that
shader playground that you
used to interactively
show the changes, is
that available online?
BRENDAN KENNY: I can
put it online.
It's dead simple, but yeah,
I can put it online.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yeah, I have a
simple question about plotting
the items on the map.
So would it be possible for
those points to have like an
additional bigger circles,
like the radius?
So my current project is, I need
to have a visualization
for overlapping schools, public
schools, particularly,
in the Philippines.
So I would need to have a range
of five kilometers.
I need to indicate if there are
overlapping schools within
a five kilometer radius.
BRENDAN KENNY: So how many
schools are you talking about?
AUDIENCE: I would be plotting
around 70,000 schools.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, so a lot.
OK, so yes.
So I actually limited the
circles because they get so
big after a while that
you lose all context.
You can't see the map anymore.
But yes, they can be
arbitrarily big.
There are some limits with point
sprites, but you can
then just switch to triangles
and pretending
they're point sprites.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's
possible, right?
So I could like mark it as red
for those schools who overlap
for, let's say, I could adjust
it like 2 kilometers, 5
kilometers.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so there's
a couple of different
ways you could do that.
You can just do it with
plain color if it's
just for visual display.
You could also use what's called
the stencil buffer,
where you can actually use, it's
like a secondary buffer,
where you can do more logical
operations like checking for
intersections and things
like that.
And you can even do something,
if you had the colors, you
could then do that read back
thing that I did for picking.
And you could even read the
color back and know, like, OK,
this is the intersection of this
kind of school and this
kind of school, if you
wanted to do that.
It might be faster do that
side on the CPU.
It's always a trade off.
But sometimes it's easier to
just shove it on the GPU and
say, take care of it.
And GPUs tend to be so fast
these days that, at least for
a prototype, it's fast enough.
And then you just need to
evaluate on real hardware and
see if it's fast enough there.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, can you
obtain a similar
effect on Google Earth?
And can you do it sharing
the same pieces of code?
BRENDAN KENNY: It would
be awesome to do
it in Google Earth.
OK, if I understand
your question.
So you're asking if you can do
this, take Google Earth and
draw the same things
on the planet.
It would be awesome.
But Google Earth is
a C++ program.
And it's more difficult to
insert yourself into that kind
of program.
And so it's difficult to
share the context.
And especially if you want to
do things like properly draw
on terrain, and not
self-intersect it,
and stuff like that.
Because if they've
done any tricks--
you would definitely
be hacking.
It would not be getting
along harmoniously.
I think it would be great
to do that, though.
And I mean, some of this is
very possible with KML.
Usually not on this scale,
usually not in the tens of
thousands of polylines,
especially if
they're long enough.
But I think we're starting to
see more and more stuff move
to the browser, kind of
with the new Maps
and things like that.
And I would love to see this
kind of thing, just plop it
right on top of WebGL globe.
I think that would be amazing.
We'll see if that happens.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I noticed you said you had
about 70,000 points.
And then here, you were talking
about millions.
What are the limits?
I didn't understand.
I have a second question, too.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right, it was
79,000 in the first one.
And it was just a query of the
database saying, for every
unique ID you have, show me the
most recent timestamped
message you have from them.
And so we had 79,000 ships
that fall within--
we had a couple of things,
like it can't be--
there's a bunch of things with
obviously wrong data, like
either their machine's messed
up, or we're parsing it wrong,
or the satellite picked
it up wrong.
So we're leaving them out.
So that's the good 79,000 that
are within the last three
months or something.
So for this, this is actually
fewer points.
So this is 20,000 ships.
So it's fewer ships, but it's
two million line segments is
what we end up drawing.
And actually, the frame rate
is good enough that I was
thinking about bumping it up.
But I didn't have time.
AUDIENCE: But my question
is, what is the limits?
Like let's say you had
a million points?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
So a million points is
definitely doable.
It depends on the hardware.
So you might have more
difficulty on older hardware.
And it's difficult to, right
now, get the feedback you need
to from the browser.
There are a bunch of browser
extensions that you can run to
get that feedback.
But it's hard to ask an end user
to run that and say, can
you copy and paste what
that just printed out.
And so but I run regularly,
on here, up to 10
million points, maybe.
And that's mostly brute
force, actually.
As long as it's not on screen,
you can actually
call it quite quickly.
And if it is on screen, you can
do things like be careful
of your alpha, so you're
not drawing too much.
But then you can start doing
things like actually
partitioning it spatially.
So you can do things like only
draw it between these
latitudes and these
longitudes.
And so you actually save a
bunch of time that way.
And so, but yeah, just brute
force, like draw it all on
screen, 10 million.
It depends on the exact blending
modes that you're
doing and things like that.
AUDIENCE: My final question
is, let's say you're a
JavaScript map programmer.
You want to learn this, is
a good place to start?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
so three.js is a
great place to start.
I've seen a number of people
start with three.js.
It's a library.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, so search
Google on three.js?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
A lot of people have
started with that.
And if they've wanted to move
on to full WebGL, there's
actually a few escape hatches
where you can say custom
element, and you specify
everything yourself, but then
lots of it is already
made for you.
Just simple things that
are already made.
But then the variety that people
come up with with that
stuff is amazing.
There's a few books.
My favorite book is still the
"OpenGL ES 2.0 Programming
Guide." It's a purple book.
And it's not actually
WebGL, but it's
close enough to WebGL.
It's basically the mirrored
API, but in C. But it's is
pretty much the same thing.
There's also two, at least,
that I know of,
of WebGL books directly.
And I haven't read either
of them, so I
can't vouch for them.
But one of them is specifically
about three.js.
And it's written
by Tony Parisi.
And he runs a blog called
"Learning WebGL" now.
And it's specifically about
that sort of thing.
And he has updates every week,
like, cool stuff that happened
around the web.
Yeah, so hopefully,
that's helpful.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
So using the color as an index
for picking is a pretty cool
trick, but kind of
limited to just
picking individual things.
It seems that for a lot of real
world stuff, you quickly
fall into sort of spatial
partitioning problems.
So do you have any advice for
how to efficiently, when
you've got really large data
sets, sort of do the spatial
partitioning for finding regions
and things like that?
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure, sure.
So you're talking like if you
wanted to be like a ranged
query and say, all the points.
So honestly, it's a little
embarrassing to do picking.
It's actually nice to
show the technique.
But it's the lazy way.
Points, especially, are some
of the easiest things to
partition and select
the nearest from.
Especially 80,000 points.
So one piece of advice I have
would be to trust JavaScript.
It's actually much faster
than a lot of people
give it credit for.
You have to kind of stick to
same things, but there's even
a lot of profiling tools
available now to tell you
exactly where you screwed up--
screwed up in the sense that
you angered the JavaScript
gods, and you de-allocated
something they assumed it was
allocating.
And they de-opted your just
in time compiled code.
But other than that, I mean,
it's really just like pretty
much the algorithms
that you expect.
So Crossfilter, which was
running that histogram at the
bottom, is actually
doing that.
They do range queries in
up to 32 dimensions.
And it's pretty fast.
WebGL is faster than it.
And so it can actually slow
down the frame rate
calculating that.
But one thing that you can do,
but I've never tried before,
is you can run it in a
web worker, so it's
in a different thread.
And actually, you're
bringing over
just the grouped histogram.
So it's much less data that
you're bringing between
processes, threads, whatever.
And so you can kind of
shove off work there.
But I would say really, the
typical space partition
algorithms that are everywhere,
and hopefully
we'll start to see more
implementations.
I've done a little bit with some
computational algebra,
computational geometry libraries
that you can check
out if you check out
my GitHub account.
And that might be helpful.
So yeah, so, any
more questions?
All right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]